foreign
[Music]
ER on Charter from Romania to London
shipping private crates
unknown
out at Sea with no land in sight
to doctor
you dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I'm on my way around the
boat our Charter has agreed to pay a
bonus for timely arrival in London
show you the ship this here is
huckleberry
we don't come with like this to give
those clear
[Applause]
something right to party animals
all the livestock this looks like a bite
search the ship everywhere
evil isn't work
[Music]
powerful evil
in night it drinks our blood he's just
here
we call him Dracula
the world is coming
see the size of that Bloody things
[Music]
he is on this ship which means that we
will never leave
the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
[Music]
foreign